what's up you little rabid rodeo bears
now rabies now rabies not s an STD right
there that's one of those unsung non
heroes you know Raby everybody wants to
preach on you know these more popular
STDs syphilis and uh you know jock itch
I guess I mean that ji boy you get up
you get a strong case of that ji-sun
that's I mean I had you growing up in
Louisiana you get that jock itch that's
the kind of you catch a strong strand
but your hands won't leave your nuts for
you know probably half of a moon cycle I
mean you you catch that strong ji boy
you don't even do you'll scratch your
wiener right off like a damn lottery
ticket you catch that I mean this they
have some strands of of jock itch down
in Louisiana that old that should be on
the Discovery Channel you know so you
know that and if you don't know it then
well now you know that Kevin Hart was
hospitalized after his car careened off
an embankment the driver of the car was
found pinned in his seat under the crust
roof and so was the female passenger and
and we know somebody that's been
involved in embankments better than
anybody I mean we're talking about the
Christopher Columbus of embankments and
and that's our man Billy conforto our IP
and right now we got a special moment
actually I'm gonna call his brother
Chuckie and get him on the line right
here and this is uh Chuckie Lowell what
up Chuck what's up I'm doing good man
how are you I'm doing okay man I was
just over in Biloxi at the casino over
there doing um a show this past weekend
so you know I had my brother's house
Saturday we had a live fantasy football
draft
yesterday actually he come back and he
was like man I went that's hilarious
well next time when I come over to the
to Louisiana I'll get you over to one
yeah be great man uh dude there's so
many fans that are that are fans of
Billy brah
yeah yeah so many people love him and um
you know and I just wanted to know like
a little bit more about him because you
know I met him we used to be was Busboys
together and uh and he was probably the
wildest dude I've ever met in my life
man you know I was I was talking to my
brother young she had seven kids in
eight years which a lot of people have a
lot of kids Jesus that's like Drew Brees
type numbers bro she had a bond we have
a bunch of baby daddies yeah I was
telling my brother's house when I was
texting you I think yesterday
my baby was like oh so like three
o'clock in the morning I was playing
cornhole and my baby's all mixed up here
but anyway we was talking it was like
this is like goes to the store and
ruling back and forth and Billy came
over one day got your bike he was wild
man yeah he was one of a kind did he I
mean I don't yeah he and I were Busboys
well I guess he was a waiter at this
restaurant and then next thing I know
dude he was always he had us always on
like all kind of weed adventures he was
doing he was running weed he was always
getting his car fixed he even give you
salt on that a little bit together what
you know
with with the Weasley I'm a song look a
capture I got it explode I forgot a
pardon from the governor which worked
out great dude I remember we was working
at the restaurant and then yeah dude I
remember I used to drive him across the
lake to get weed and we would come back
with so much weed brah
well the person he was coming to oh
there we go yeah well look nice too nice
to talk to you again man dude and y'all
had the craziest [ __ ] family people
was box and people was uh I mean people
were that people were on pills
everything was going on yeah drugs they
taught family apart
you know it was Billy then three cousins
we took and you know your boys could box
I mean they were good they were gone
somewhere but that monkey got on they
couldn't get it off it was tough on you
know it's what do you do you know they
don't want to be that way talk to Billy
about it all the time like Billy would
get these are you getting these moves
where you know he wouldn't see him for a
while and we all knew he was gone but
then he would show up get the camera out
he always had this Polaroid camera and
he would take a picture and he was like
I'm holding on to the picture and we're
gonna tell you no pictures right so then
we would go work out hard and he
wouldn't let you I couldn't skip you
couldn't cut a rep sorry he was
that's how Billy was and even like I
heard one you cast about the steroids he
said that I had a flashback oh my god
Billy's the Buick that I remember like
he was doing to think like winch crossed
something crazy and yeah and I kind of
like man I'm playing football I want to
try that too so he's like it's gonna be
the routine and this is how we gonna eat
he was right at all crazy like a mad
scientist and he was like so he would
tell you we gotta take it a half hour
before we work out and when you said
that I remember distinctly one time
being in the car a half hour before the
gym pull over I'm like wait listen wait
oh let's go to the apartment or
something
your apartment is around the corner from
the gym no we gotta stop
now in doing we actually was sure it's
not that happened then we did it over
off of the interstate over but between
Slidell and uh the exit bought a movie
theater brought we would duck off of it
in [ __ ] pipe him down boy
and I hate to cut that call short right
there but you can listen to the entire
call on our second YouTube channel Theo
von Clips so you can check that channel
out and it's got a lot of unique stuff
on it and it will have the entire
conversation with Chuck Billy's brother
Wow just fascinating man and that yeah
and I talked to him for nearly an hour
so you guys can enjoy that there but
yeah being able to chat with the just I
mean I'm real I mean just that human
Fiasco that uh that Billy conforto was
getting to talk to his brother man
pretty sweet
let's get into this episode how about
that
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from
mine and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it
[Music]
little time for me to snap that pocket
break I said and tell you my story
[Music]
I know me and I will find a song singing
and as you know it is Bishop Gunn shine
taking us in right there bringing us
into the world I wonder if when you're
born like you could hear I wish they had
a little bit of that womb music you know
I wonder if maybe when you're born they
should play certain music and it not you
know it might help you come into the
world a little bit better or different
you know it would be like you know like
you know like that song Sanyal it might
be you know just a real natural kind of
Christian birth right there you could
have some rap music if you want if that
baby was just kind of you don't even
know if you're gonna you know if you're
that excited about the baby
you know or if you kind of just hooked
up with a man and you don't even know
that man maybe they have that song below
but I had asked too fast polo but I had
asked too fast and they could play that
in the delivery room so at least a baby
when he comes into the world he kind of
knows how he got out there you know all
right you know he might not have it
immediately his backstory might be the
embedded into his tissue by the music
because music hides in our bodies boy
isn't that fascinating
music hides in our bodies I mean I'm you
if you you know if you [ __ ] carve me
open with uh what a carve opener or
whatever you um I'll probably have a
little bit of top 40 in me you
definitely gonna find some Goo Goo Dolls
down there by my ass you feel me you're
gonna hear you know because music it one
time a guy you know hit punched me
really hard right in the jaw and
immediately I started hearing that song
in the end the only thing that matters
you know that Linkin Park that dude just
punch us and that song so you know that
was hidden in my jar something let's do
[ __ ] crack me and next thing you know
I'm Linkin Park and boy and that dude
parallel parked my ass onto the ground
and my brain just you know I got Lincoln
parked up because music hides Enya
somebody might hit you with a damn you
know if somebody you know might hit you
with a damn uh like a beater stick like
a stick used for for beating others they
hit you with that [ __ ] in the back and
next thing you know you start I keep a
close watch on this heart of mine
they'll beat the [ __ ] Johnny Cash
right out of you that's the thing that
music could really hide in our bodies so
if when a baby was born they put a
little bit of music on that maybe really
you put that you know some some just
some music like one of them Jamaican
guys like kind of a weed you know um I'm
not thinking of Bobby Marley
Bobby Marley you know no woman no cry
they get that in you and it really
affect your system positively I think
over time
shout out to everybody and support to
everybody over there dealing with the
hurricane and it's that time of year you
know Mother Nature has got a recipe book
out because because you got that summer
is kind of settling down you got the
rain the rain is coming in winter and
Mother Nature's just kind of flipping
through the pages okay what we got okay
we got a scattered storm over there you
know we're gonna make a entree out here
in the on the coast we're gonna mix up a
batch of durian send that [ __ ] up to
feed a couple of a couple hundred
thousand with some water that's what you
know it's just that time of year when
Mother Nature really has a recipe book
out
and can you know when she's brewing up
things she's making a batch of something
nasty it's that time of year winter is
coming
newbie that's the crit you can't winner
nothing do my brother I remember at all
when we were young when we were children
we used to wait for the bus and do
getting out there and a bus in a winter
time you know it would be like two days
a year it would freeze in Louisiana and
people were crazy even who hit freeze
people just duct-tape a blanket around
their kid and [ __ ] sent him to school
just you see you see people walking
around school just look like tall just
stacks a blanket you have to open up the
top and see who it was
oh who is this oh that's a little
Randall right there you know oh look you
you have to unfold the blanket at the
top like oh that's Bridget and Bridget
all [ __ ] duct-tape kids looking all
kidnapped kind of but warm and you would
just get so you know you get out there
by the bus stop and breathe in the air
and just make them ghosts you know me
and you can see your air you can see
your breath living you know just forming
outside of you beautiful just be uh
and we would do I remember if my hands
you know my brother my brother one time
sometime would have gas you know body
gas you know you know what I'm talking
about body gas man farms and he would
give you a set of air mittens dude if
your hands was real cold he'd have he'd
say hey put him put him over by my butt
and he'd hit you with them warm he'd hit
you with that a dose of that warm body
air and give you those just so his hand
mittens bro just lace you out with a set
of air mittens right there keep your
hands warm for about 15 18 second and
that's teamwork too man it really is
teamwork
you know cuz it's that's the thing about
being in a winter place it brings people
together you get that togetherness you
have you got a snuggle you know the
plants are dying so you got to take care
of each other you know people's lives
become more pertinent when you got the
winter going on you got to be careful
you can't step certain places because
you'll slip you'll die because of the
ice so you have to be real careful and I
think that things seem a little more
precious in the wintertime human life
does because it's at a little bit more
of a rarity it's not as abundant as it
is but yet everybody who's bracing for
Dorian and dealing with it good luck to
you stay strong out there dude and I say
get out there and be a hero get out
there and be a damn hero we had a boy in
our town what is dude a little Chico
they called him and he was black I guess
he was he was like a young black
gentleman or he might have been just
kind of dark Mexican you know kind of
like you know like you know dark Mexican
and he would get out there and he if a
storm was coming he'd get out there with
a sore breath this dude he was fearless
he'd be out there battling the wind cuz
you know in Louisiana they get them
gusts and a gust I'll hit you at 40
miles an hour and [ __ ] tickle your
ass real hard like a pervy uncle bruh a
strong wind gust he'll [ __ ] just make
it get you get all your tenderness and
and he would look chico be out there
with a [ __ ] sword bruh and he was
real real he was real light his bones
probably if you were holding all of his
bones in your hands you if you weren't
you might not even know if you what you
might not even know you were holding
that's how light he was he was just you
know he didn't have a lot of uh calcium
in him and his daddy was real light his
dad would I remember one time fell off
the roof and just
kind of went side-to-side and then just
kind of landed on the stomach real
softly so it's just the family not real
they had low calcium and that's that's
you know it's uh I don't know if it's a
birth defect or what it is but it's God
it's God doing what he likes but look
Chico brah oh this dude also the
craziest thing about him
he always he would look for Easter eggs
year-round so he was that kind of dude
he look you you know you know you be
outside he'd be always looking for
Easter eggs and I think he didn't really
get the whole concept of an Easter egg
hunt he thought it was you know I don't
know I guess one of them he went to the
first one he ever went to and he just
thought that life had changed and now he
could always look for him but I remember
he come over for dinner sometime and
he'd [ __ ] spend half that half the
meal looking for eggs but I round the
house and [ __ ] like damn little chick oh
boy get you a little dark Latino ass
back here dude we trying to [ __ ]
finish off these potatoes boy are we and
getting any cookies little buddy but he
really loved Easter eggs man he would
always and then he got depressed really
I remember a little bit as we got older
because he didn't find you know it was
so rare that you found eggs and so he
you know when you're constantly looking
for something you don't get it sometime
it can really lead to some depression
but but that's life what else is going
on I've been in training in Atlanta for
a week training we did training for
movie training and working with it was
like working with um you had assault
rifles ar-15 and you had Navy SEAL
trainers training people how to interact
with the weaponry how to use the
weaponry how to maneuver and move as a
group really next level type of stuff I
think just handling that piece because
you I want to get out there and [ __ ]
Clint Eastwood you know I hold an ar-15
to the side and just
but it's very organized and very and we
got to shoot blanks I get to shoot
blanks which was film blanks and so they
make a louder flash than regular bullets
do and they make a louder sound but they
don't have any projectile so that was
kind of interesting to see and we
learned also though that that the the
blanks even if you had like a water
bottle the man showed us and you shot it
from about six feet away it would
obliterate it so even the blanks the air
blast that comes out of the weaponry is
extremely severe so you have to be
cognizant of that you can't just be you
know shooting blanks at people because
people will believe to death but uh what
else did we do um you know it was just
like you get there and there's the
script as the table read and everybody's
you know it was just a lot it was a lot
in one week and just kind of seeing
what's going on with it and and getting
to meet Christopher Pratt we'd never met
very nice man the director everybody
they are beautiful people let's uh but I
was there for a week and then I went to
Biloxi and a call actually came in from
Biloxi and I'll hit that one right here
um here we go
yo John I'm at grief from Spanish fort
Alabama what's up John and Spanish fort
and I got a stepsister that lives over
here in Spanish fort over there and
they're doing well les she gots two
children one of them's a ginger real
tall tall ganger home word just calling
to let you know man you did the damn
thing in Biloxi last night ten my wife
and I are still laughing and talking
about the show man we had a [ __ ]
glass everything he said was [ __ ]
hilarious and on point at all time the
show was great the opening act was
[ __ ] amazing everything was perfect
man so when
except for the knucklehead ladies
sitting behind me but you called her out
on that [ __ ] with her loud ass gang
gang there you go thanks for calling man
yeah that was fun in Biloxi that lady I
did call her out there that was good too
she said oh you should have a Mexican
kid I remember she yelled and I was like
well if I want to have a loud kid I'll
come talk to you that's what I said
so we really put her in the Silence
booth didn't we
yeah man Biloxi's crazy you down there
on the Gulf Coast you dude they got
everything they got fish swimming
through the air down there
they got trout they got this they got
carp
you know they got carpenter you'll see
carpenters but it's just for fish
[ __ ] doing some drywall I mean they
got real fish everywhere it's real just
fish dick ulis down there but thank you
guys for coming out it was a lot of fun
man it was fun so many people came you
know and just to be down there on the
Gulf Coast and you can't even get any
cocaine down there cuz it's wet
everything's wet down here you find an
oyster in a damn cocaine you'll do half
a line and [ __ ] next thing you know
you got a pearl you know you just you
got a you know you got a pearl that you
found so it's it's a different place man
but it was yeah it was a joy bro it was
a real real joy of a tear and people
came out what else happened man I was
gonna tell you guys about something that
happened um something that that I was
thinking about Oh
Louisiana won the Little League World
Series that's what I was thinking about
I want to say congratulations to em boys
Southwest baby that team and they took
they be Curacao
they beat Hawaii and what I'm saying is
they beat everybody son a bunch of
little freaking uh low Gator tales from
over there in Louisiana man from River
Ridge from over there outside of New
Orleans they really got it done so
congratulations to them little boys and
dude I remember bro being in a little
league I
so [ __ ] bad at baseball you know I
was bad I was bad at baseball dude they
put me in left field and then at one
point they put me in double left field
brah I wasn't even on the field I was
like you know if you go to left field
there's a line right there where that's
out of bounds and they put me over there
one time so at that point you're only
like an assistant coach really and I
remember dude I remember one time he put
me so far out there I was body's woods I
was about probably 11 or 12 feet deep
into some woods and I could barely even
hear the game so that's you know and I
remember they had a couple mushrooms out
there and I remember eating a couple of
those [ __ ] boy and look you playing
baseball and you have a couple mushrooms
bruh the whole world becomes the
outfield they die
I don't know what game I was playing did
I wa I was playing Connect four inside
of my brain bruh I was trying to
rearrange my toes I was trying to put
him in a more I was looking at my feet I
remember thinking if I could put my toes
in a more effective order and that was
just so you got to be careful sometimes
with those games you know these kids
some of the kids they didn't and my
favorite thing was getting the snow cone
at the end after the game you know
you're a shitty baseball player when
your favorite part of the sport is
getting that snack after that's that you
know that's when I remember the coach
sometimes he was a hate deal go sit in
my truck
make sure it's cooling off that's what
he would say because he'd keep the AC
running in there and I'd sit in there
for 20 minutes while the other kids were
practicing and just [ __ ] I must have
been horrible god I must've been
horrible at this [ __ ]
dang so bear grylls you all know him and
the funny thing is his name Bear Grylls
but never once have I seen him eating
any Kodiak Boy brown
back grizzly polar bear I haven't seen
him grill up one slice of bear Brook you
can't have a name and not do it okay
what if your name was wizard daddy and
you don't do any spells bruh then that's
really not really neat is it then you're
not living up to your name or what if
your name is blind Simon but when people
say Simon you don't even react and you
can see really well then you're not who
you say you are bear grylls first of all
grill up a little bit bit of bear I'd
like to see you carve up a [ __ ] cut a
cub baby okay and gum that [ __ ] down you
don't see how strong you would be so
bear grylls don't even grill bear but he
got stung by a bee and had to be rushed
out by paramedics and I'll say this man
if you don't think that bees are the
Doberman Pinschers of the devil bees are
Satan's little German shepherds
think about it be think about a bee man
they they come around bruh and they [ __ ]
you up
think about that imagine if somebody ran
over by you you're hanging out at the
park you having a little cut of ham or
something you know you may be having a
couple gangers snaps or whatever doing
something natural you have an eliminate
rub but you cut it down with water a
little because it's too sugar and
somebody runs up bra a little dude huh
runs up pulls out a [ __ ] knife
[ __ ] pokes you like that and then he
dies that's a bee that's a bee man
that's what a bee do bees do that kind
of [ __ ] bro Abbey would kill you if it
could the problem is God don't give a be
a strong enough sword just a [ __ ]
hurt you but bear if you can't handle a
bee sting dude I remember getting stung
by a bee bro and both of my [ __ ]
eyelids boy at the park one time during
summer camp and I still had to go to
camp my mom didn't give a damn you can't
see do well you know God wants you to
relax on the inside a little bit and
calm down you know you just darkened out
but you still have to go to summer camp
I'm gonna give it down I wanna put some
calamine lotion on my [ __ ] forehead
she even put it on my eyes I remember
made me go made me drink a whole bunch
of water [ __ ] was horrible boy but
different times man but Bear Grylls boy
you can't handle a bee sting that's
crazy
what's going on man everything let's get
another call that came in here the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and first also
let's say this man that this episode is
brought to you by better help better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you know I've been seeing a
therapist for a while I had been and
recently I stopped seeing them seeing
her as a woman you know and now I'm
gonna go back I just decided yesterday I
needed to go back to seeing a therapist
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 24 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help but it
is professional counseling done securely
online sometimes you don't want to go to
a therapist and tan you don't want to
walk you know you don't want to be seen
walking into a therapists office but we
need help sometimes we need help and I
want to talk about that in a second why
I feel like young men now need more help
or are appearing to need more help but
better help you can log in your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor there's a broad range of
expertise and better helps counselor
network it's more affordable than
traditional offline counts
and financial aid is available better
help wants you to start living a happier
life today and I do believe that if you
can find ways to get out of your head
the maze that is in your head or to
maybe make the walls of that maze not as
high that you can live a more
comfortable life because I found that to
be true for myself
you can visit better help.com theö th e
oh that's better
h ELP and join the over 500,000 people
talk taking charge of their mental
health with help of an experienced
professional there's a special offer for
this past weekend listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm /
Theo and you can find a therapist or
counselor that you can you can speak
with them on the phone you can FaceTime
you can FaceTime on the computer Skype
you can text with them you just people
you can communicate with that can
sometimes help us think outside of
ourselves because sometimes we can't
handle it ourselves better help calm /
Theo 10% off your first month you know I
was in I was actually I was working out
this morning and I got a trainer got a
trainer you know I'm just because I
struggle I know sometimes with the
motivation so if I can help cure that
part then I can be more effective and
actually you know breaking breaking a
sweat and doing that kind of stuff it's
it's a good use of my time because it
makes it takes me out of my brain and
this morning I was thinking man I was
having to do these like sled pushes and
stuff and and I was like man sometimes
when I kept thinking like how this is
hard it was hard but then at one point I
was like well I'm gonna quit thinking
with my brain and just think with my
body you know why don't I just let my
body take control of the moment instead
of sitting there thinking this is hard
but I'm gonna just use my legs and see
how hard it really is and once I did
that I started feeling I was like oh
this isn't as hard as I thought it was
and it made me think of a lot of times
like when I you know I used to lay in
bed a lot and just start my brain would
just run and start thinking negative
right when I wake up my brain just man
you got this
this thing is deal hanging over your
head and this and you know maybe here's
a lie that you told and you haven't
really straightened it out yet and that
comes back the land I'm on my shoulder
like a bird every morning and and then
this problem you know you got this you
know you know you got this business
thing you got to take care of and you
need to respond on all these little
birds land on my shoulders right when I
wake up and it's all and it's negative
chirping but that's just if I lay there
and listen to my brain but if I get
moving and get my feet going and get
into my body then I find oh well
obviously I'm getting things done my
brains not able to just talk to me
because I'm actually taking control I'm
doing something and then I was thinking
man maybe one of the reasons why a lot
of young men in my generation and the
generation after me are struggling with
mental health or just you know more
caught up in our feelings and our
emotions and [ __ ] is because we don't
use our bodies as much as we used to
like our fathers are you know and our
grandfathers they had to a lot of them
worked more labor jobs you know a lot of
them there wasn't everything wasn't
automated they had to move more they had
to do more things so they were more in
their body they were taking action
physical action whereas now it's like a
lot of us aren't a lot of those jobs
don't exist things are more automated so
we get more in our brain you know and I
think our brains just aren't used to
being able to just be so sedentary and
when the brain gets sedentary you know
one just sits around and it's not you
know it's when it's when your body's
moving your brain has to kind of like
control just function of what's going on
but when or when my body is moving when
my body is still my brain just starts to
just swirl you know it just starts to do
pontificate and consider and worry but
if I keep my body moving my brains like
okay I got to pay attention to what's
going on cuz I have to make sure the
body is okay you know I can't bump into
things or run into a you know a saw or
something or you know get hit by you
know something do it you know catch some
electricity or something
so so what I'm saying is like I noticed
that when I was pushing on this sled at
the gym when I when I was in my brain I
was like [ __ ] this is hard man down but
if I could do this and how much longer
do I have but when I quit that and just
started moving my body I couldn't think
about the worry I just could you know I
just got it done and I think that's
where we are as a generation and so
there's a lot more young men who just
this is the first and second generations
of us not using our bodies as much you
know not as many people work in labor
jobs not as many people so you're having
more of a sedentary lifestyle where your
brain starts moving and and I think that
that's why we're having just because
we're more caught in our brains and
we're having more mental health issues
because we're using our brains all the
time but but we're not using them in
conjunction with our body at the same
time so there's just a thought that I
had it was something that really kind of
resonated with me like wow like no
wonder you know we don't we're not
moving as much if we move less than yeah
we're gonna have more mental health
problems because we're just stagnant and
so made me think about you know kind of
some of the stuff that you know like wow
if I get moving my brain doesn't have a
chance to just sit there and spin so
let's take another call that came in
here nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three is the hotline and if
you hit that sucker be much obliged also
we got the new mercs lineup you can
check it out
and I think the link will be below in
the YouTube homework hey Theo my name is
Hanna
I was calling regards called you got
last week about a guy with sweaty hands
Oh Thank You Hannah I appreciate that
call yeah that fella was real dripped
out up in the midst you know he really
he got those uh he's got he's kind of
got his guerrillas in them in the mitts
you know he's got them you know he's got
that he's dampened out because I hand
really I mean there's so much moisture
in our bodies it's really amazing that
more of it just doesn't pass right
through our hand you got water blood
plasma it's amazing it'll shake
somebody's hand and they have a little
bit of plasma on their hands sometimes
let's hear more and this is actually how
you've probably heard of it it's a
medical issue called hyperhidrosis and I
had it in my armpit so just not you at
all it could be something like that you
heard though you couldn't get Botox in
your hands I got Botox of my arms if my
answers actually covered it is provided
like proof night you so you can get that
boat touching Botox in your hands for
handshake and I guess if he's slipping
out you get that hello tox broke as you
shake somebody saying you say hello and
then but just dry it up if you got that
because that's I mean that just seems
extensive and how many injections you
have to get to get a whole shake covered
because if you know or I guess you just
really need to get the middle but yeah
you want that dry grip often think if
you're doing handshakes that's the
biggest concern is hitting somebody with
that [ __ ] wet hello right out the
gate you're just hitting them with that
damn with this you know you put up a
just that slick snake boy that's [ __ ]
that palem and ER you know you making
pals with somebody and then that thing's
all slippery that arm that hand and
that's something that's really probably
but that's called hyperhidrosis okay so
you're saying that he could get
injections Botox in his hands and you've
had it in your armpits and that's kind
of sexy a little bit if you're making
love to somebody and you just start real
just just really just almost just kind
of just really just getting all Niagra
on your ribs kind of it's almost a
little bit sexy let's hear more
dermatologist or something they have to
assess like need and you have to say
that you like tried a bunch of [ __ ] so
it's six months nowhere I haven't been
fighting anywhere company aren't it so
yeah I had a friend that had the same
this year arson on a horrible she would
write essays and just smear the ink all
over the place where essays couldn't be
grated so she's got Botox on her hands
and she's all good now and there you go
if you don't want to do good school work
just [ __ ] tell them you got that drip
get you a little thing of Visine and
just put some on your hands show to
teacher say look these answers are bad
but it's because I'm [ __ ] leaked out
you know daddy's got that I got those uh
I got those little Oasis's right here
well what do they call mirages or
something fake little rivers or
something
here's another call that came in for the
drippy mitts for some advice for the
beautiful young fella and him and his
daddy got that genetic drip gang gang
homework API Kevin from Los Angeles
what's up Kevin from Los Angeles thank
you for calling man and and I'm in Los
Angeles right now brother so let's hear
more part of the call really quickly to
help out a guest I called you he had an
issue with some leaky myths right I had
that problem for like 27 years
damn so you really one of the
forefathers of those [ __ ] of those
those arm faucets homeward just terrible
you don't want to
networking events don't want to shake
anyone Pam well now the fist bump has
really saved you guys then because a lot
of people had issues with the fist bump
when it came out saying it was violent
so I was promoting violence it was a
black power thing that you know just
people felt it was egregious but anyway
enough of what I'm thinking
onward thank you Kevin no yeah I could
imagine that would but now if he's gonna
do a little masturbation then that's
gotta be helpful homework what I did is
I looked up there's a thing called Ione
tuck derma and I think the ion is like
ions for electricity it's this weird
thing you put your hands in a little bit
of water and I don't know what it does
like electrocutes
something in your hand you know and I
turned off the sweat glands or something
like that and you literally solved my
problems within like you know two
treatments and now I do it like once
every two weeks hands and feet and it's
dry and it's life changing dude so
hopefully your guests can hear this and
it can help them out because it's
definitely helped me out guy own took
derma and hopefully that changes his
life hi man take care I know it's a
derma and yeah we'll put this in it
together in a package and put this on
the clips channel as well you'll be able
to see that if you got yeah if you
dripping up those paws if you got those
porous pause and then this could be some
solution well those are two great
suggestions thank you guys both a
hyperhidrosis and the Ione subdermal and
you put your hands in some electric
water and that tight and just [ __ ] up
doing because that's crazy can you play
basketball you're getting the ball all
wet you know you can't even uh I guess
it's nice if you're fixing your hair and
you wish you had a little bit of gel but
you don't cuz a lot of times I wish I
had a little moisture on my hand to
tighten up my wig and then BAM so I
guess there's things that help and
things that don't but also dude I gotta
say this I got the worst haircut of my
life in Biloxi
Mississippi and maybe I shouldn't have
got my hair cut at a casino that's the
truth
but damn do that [ __ ] just broke my
heart man
this lady and I think she shouldn't have
been cutting hair dude she I swear brush
she had a pair of damn school scissors
in there and I knew right when I sat
down she goes oh I'm really one of the
best hair cutters and I said like this
ain't gonna be real well and I told her
just a little and then she went wild
like she was doing gardening but I
wouldn't let this lady cut dude she
couldn't if she was trying to cut her
own wrists I bet she couldn't this lady
and I hate to get upset man but there's
nothing that mate that makes it tougher
for me then if somebody [ __ ] my hair up
my haircuts already [ __ ] up so I'm not
letting people cut my hair anymore you
know I'm not doing that [ __ ] man that
lady and I knew it at one point
at one point I said please stop and I
sat there boy and I knew it and all I
could see was how horrible I was gonna
look for the next five weeks just
knowing that this that this is how
things had occurred and that [ __ ] chewed
me bruh and she just the back is she
made it all thin and [ __ ] and and I
don't know man and I and then here's the
worst she didn't even tidy up around my
neck you know you get all that
straggling [ __ ] on the back of your neck
looked like a newborn animal a little
bit you get that that fuzz and stuff in
your ears
she didn't even tighten any of it up
dude but what I that's what I like I
sometimes I just man why'd I get my hair
cut at a casino man just pissing me off
do some of the choices I make I should
have known that [ __ ] man do-right night
there was selling candy and [ __ ] and
they got dude 60 feet away they got
everybody's on a gay got one of their
hitting that air tank and people dude
how many able but able bodied people are
on these scooters and [ __ ] Atticus
no I saw a whole school like a school of
fish go by like 30 people all of them
look fine physically and now out here
just just in a v-formation i said dang
boy come on somebody with a bow and
arrow start popping these [ __ ] off
[Music]
but yeah man that's where you see this
kind of stuff do people just get up and
go dude the old days somebody had one
leg while you see them hopping to their
gate at the airport you see them yeah
yeah yeah okay
do you need some help yeah hey let me
get on your back for a second people
helping each other out now everybody's
in the wheelchair you'll see fine just
that's how they do it now it's just
different you know you got the big
family everybody's sharing a gas tank I
think a gas or something or air oxygen
at the Ksenia on these scooter I'm
telling you man
put these [ __ ] out in left
field I'm feisty today
I'll be okay everybody's okay man you
know it's just we got to get back in our
physical bodies we got to stay active
because it keep our brain from running
overtime keeping our brain from running
over time what else man here's a
question that came in from patreon this
from Dalton Windham how has it been
getting away from Los Angeles for a
while do you think staying away for
several weeks will push you to relocate
like you've mentioned before gang gang
you know what's funny man I think even
just having been in Atlanta for the past
week I start to get an idea of okay this
is what life would be like if I live
somewhere else you know there was some
good things you know Atlanta
is Atlanta's cool man is so spread out
it actually reminds me of Los Angeles a
lot a lot of places the food services
River the places I ate out was not good
you wait forever to eat at a certain
point I thought I'd just take up hunting
I said man am I to go to the damn hunt
if this is how long it's gonna take to
get a damn burger but also it could be
I'm coming from Los Angeles where you
know you get used to thing being quicker
and fastness things have more fast and
sent them out here oh I thought of this
too if you got the drippy mitts dude
have my brother serve you a set of them
[ __ ] air mittens baby have somebody
you know throw a little uh but a little
burst on the little body gas on your
hands boy dry them cats right up but
what else do I think is I mean get away
from Austin for a while oh I definitely
think that the pace out here is not a
pace that's the same in the rest of
America it's just different you know the
rest of America feels a little bit more
like everything is more at home and more
laid-back and then you get into some
city environments and it feels like
you're just used to things being quicker
so I think I need to it shows me that my
level of patience has gotten accelerated
so I need a lesson now I need to take a
little bit of a psi out of my ability to
be patient let's take another call that
came in right here nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three see oh man
I'm working down in San Diego as a
machinist again look oh nice man that
gunsmith did I'll tell you it is so you
know this week we were working with
these pistols these AR guns ar-15s and
they're really fancified for the movies
they teach it they make all put on extra
scopes and they make them real you know
cinematic and and and one other thing I
noticed was
Oh so uh what am I thinking about he
said he's machinist he's gone Smith
who's gunsmith do I know that I'm sorry
I'm an amine oh here's one thing I
realized about police officers police
officers you know get a ton of bad press
I mean the press is basically it will
raise hell about anything just to get
clicks they don't really care anymore
it's not news it's just how can we start
fire today how can we start Hell today
how can we say anything is basically
someone just yelling it's almost like
schizophrenia has a bunch of large
companies a lot of these news stations
I'm not kidding watch CNN anymore rough
you up a few it's not even a [ __ ]
television it's a I just I don't know
man I just don't know what's going on
with that [ __ ] but I'll say this here
that when I remember when I was um when
I was working on the on road rules show
we went one time to Georgia went to
North Georgia and they had a it was how
to be a police officer when two police
officer training and one of the things
you did you went into a simulator
simulator you know something that makes
something that's not that and we went in
there and the simulator was you had you
were an officer and you had a sidearm
and you were in this room and that was
the and the simulator was against the
wall there was a big screen and the
screen would play different scenarios
and like you would be like an officer
that caught got called to go to a an
alley where people were something was
happening there's stuff going on at this
alley you know as a domestic disturbance
or something and so on the screen it
would look like an alley it would look
like behind a building and there's
people out there and somebody's you know
standing there with their girlfriends
somebody's you know leaning on the
dumpster smoking a cigarette it looked
like an alley and
in this simulator you could talk to the
screen and it was all like the computers
and stuff made it so it would talk back
they would communicate back so you could
talk to somebody who was in the scene
that you were watching so you say hey
you know what are you doing out here and
the guy would talk back to you and and
you would kind of go through these
different kind of checkpoints that a
police officer has to go through now
sometimes during the simulation they had
different settings on the simulation
where sometimes one of the people in the
scene would pull out a weapon and just
start shooting at you and when that
happened inside of the room you are in
they had these fake they had these like
guns in the wall that would shoot these
rubber pellets at you or shoot these
plastic pellets at you so if something
happened on the screen on the simulator
it would then and somebody shot at you
it would happen in then real pellets
would shoot out of the wall out of the
corners out of these kind of like
paintball gun type of things and
actually hit you but sometimes the guy
on the screen would just it would look
like he was just he would retain in his
pocket to show you his identification
and it was just real interesting because
I remember thinking man I would engage
in different scenarios like sometime
you're in a classroom sometimes you're
there's you know you're pulling people
over at anti-vehicle and it really blew
my mind how well one time a guy could be
reaching just to get to his
identification or to just scratch his
leg and another time a guy could reach
to pull up weapon on you and it blew my
mind my inability to be able to
calculate those in real time because
they they'd have the same scenario you
know you it would be like an officer
response you know and use you know
there's five people in an alley and it
turns out all they were doing was
gamblin or they were looking for
something somebody thrown something away
in a dumpster now they're all planning
on looking for it and and the scenario
could play out like a thirty different
ways and the computer would have it set
up like that but when you when you
engage with them like you didn't really
know every time it you had no idea how
it was going to play out
and so you know it was just and so
sometimes you get shot and sometimes you
it would be just nothing it would just
be oh you know there's a cat somebody's
looking for their cat and that's what
you're trying to help with but you never
knew and and just the way it changed
sometimes so quick you know you'd be in
a like you had to respond to a classroom
and one of the scenarios they had his
guy had his head on the desk and you're
talking to a student in the front of the
class who had been an up in an argument
with another student or something and
then somebody the guy in the back just
sits up one time and gets his bookbag to
leave the room but in another version of
that same scenario the guy gets up and
and pulls out a weapon and just to be
able to like know the difference or be
able to like in the Manute seconds that
you're standing there to watch on the
screen and be able to know okay what's
gonna happen right now
that [ __ ] was baffling man it was so
hard to be able to know to be able to
have reflexes that made sense or to be
able to be it was impossible sometimes
it was impossible
you think a guy was a guy was just a
full opening a newspaper and next thing
you know you pull and you shoot on him
and another time a guy's it looks like
he's opening newspaper he pulls a gun
out and starts shooting at you but to
know it just blew my mind man anyway
when you when you said about guns made
me think about that about that
experience I had a long time ago
and I thought about this past week when
I was uh handling the weaponry out there
and handling a different violent you
know utensils in this and net homework
that's doing pretty well um I had a
falling out with my boss who you got let
go which wasn't too bad
I felt pretty down at first because I
just gotten arrested for a DUI and
that's just about how I was gonna pay
for that and everything and my wonderful
girlfriend helped find me a new
machinists and gunsmith job and I was
you know really looking out feeling good
about it you know I'm and I really meant
stuff I had a little incident at work
and I got scared
I had you know mess something up
I try to hide it I lied about it oh man
I'm sorry to hear that man I've done
that before you know I'm supposed to
just be doing washing tools one time and
I took this tool truck for a ride and I
tried to jump a ditch with it and
[ __ ] [ __ ] man I [ __ ] everything up
Jesus Christ
let's hear more at first and you know I
came clean right afters I didn't want
you know doesn't matter didn't want none
of that and I don't blame them I should
know how about it and it just really
sucks because you know now I don't know
what I'm gonna do I embarrass my
girlfriend home to get the job one of my
buddies who you know he's his reference
and I understand and I just made a fool
of myself and I feel really bad and just
today I crushed my hand man didn't feel
too good I had to go get some stitches
right after leaving the hospital I
[ __ ] reared in some lady on the
hospital now so my main question is I
can't really seem to keep my head on
straight like I was missing I just keep
messing up I don't know if anybody has
some advice out there
much appreciated game game you know just
man I love you all right bye love you
too bro I love you too man I'm sorry
you're struggling with some of these
things I know such a bad it's such a
tough feeling when you feel like you
just everywhere you turn you you make
mistakes or you mess things up or you
know and um I can really relate to that
man I can really relate to thinking
because then I start thinking I'm no
good I'm no good as a person that's
where that when that kind of stuff
happens in my life
I start thinking I'm no good as a person
and then I don't want to interact with
other people anymore because I feel like
oh man
every time I interact with people I just
end up kind of messing their lives up or
doing something bad and and the safest
thing for me to do is just stay away
from others and be and just keep to
myself but then when I do that the
little dark arts really can bloom even
stronger because I'm just
alone with my thoughts and let me say
this man my brother helped me realize
this recently that what I do and who I
am are can be different things if I make
mistakes that doesn't mean that I'm a
mistake okay you're a good person you
have made some choices that didn't work
out the way you wanted them to you
probably feel the repercussions of those
are really huge and you can't surmount
them but you can you know and all these
things aren't happening at once you know
I know it feels like they are but you
can solve them one at a time now if you
apologize to somebody you can't expect
them maybe to immediately accept the
apology
and be okay that's now that's that's
something we can't expect but you can
let them know hey this is the choice I
made this is why I made it I made a
mistake let me know how can if there's
something I can do to remedy the
situation I know you helped me get this
job let me know what it is I think if
you're honest and sincere then you can
repair those those damages I really
believe that now you may not repair them
immediately it may take a little bit of
time for those to completely repair or
get better so just recognize that don't
don't think if that doesn't hey did you
know they don't accept me immediately or
they don't that that you're that
everything's horrible or it's never
gonna happen that's not true
but the choices you make are things that
happen or things you do or things you're
a part of and who you are those are two
different things man you know this
doesn't mean you're a bad person that
doesn't mean you're not going to be
successful that doesn't mean you're not
capable it doesn't mean you don't
deserve to live in this world or to be a
part of a loving relationship or to have
somebody care about you this dud that
doesn't mean any of these things
you know it sounds like um you maybe
could just use some help overall it
seems like with the way that you are
operating in the world you know
sometimes the way that we think the
world is and the way that it really is
are a little bit off and for me I got in
and that's why I could this got into
twelve-step and stuff like that recovery
programs because those things really
helped me you know always thought that
everybody was I was a little I don't
know I thought that it was all about me
like I don't know sometimes I still do I
don't know I try and think of what I
thought I always thought that life was
this weird competition kind of that
everybody was keeping all these scores
and nobody was it wasn't really
happening people were just trying to
survive and people were just and for the
most part people were trying to do well
and they were trying to do well by one
another and when I learned to interact
with the world at an easier softer way
things got easier for me in every asset
and every facet relationships employment
you know I learned how to uh you know
just the value of telling the truth
sometimes a lot about [ __ ] man and that
he shouldn't even have still do
sometimes but not like I was before man
and I felt like the world didn't want me
that it just like I was just hearing it
sometimes and now I know I'm a part of
it just like other people are and then
we all make mistakes and a lot of times
people are really understanding when
they when you're really being honest
with them there's somewhere inside of me
a long time ago I felt like if I was
honest with people that they weren't
gonna love me I think you know what I
think is some of that just went back to
maybe at a young age or you know maybe I
felt like I was really expressing need
and I didn't get the response that I
wanted and so somewhere inside of me
that part of me closed up and didn't
really open up correctly again
but that's not true man you did there's
a couple of things that have occurred
and you can you can remedy them for
yourself and you can change the way that
you behave so that they don't happen
again so you don't feel this way again
and that's what I did find when I got
into 12-step and the type of stuff as I
found an easier softer way to live which
I didn't think existed man God you know
I thought that the world like I still
feel like I sometimes I take my own
willpower back so much and it's like I
just I'm trying to control everything
and man I can't do that I can't do that
and thank God I can't if the world
revolved around me dude it would fall
apart you know I don't even have any
milk at home so [ __ ] you know how I'm
doing but it's gonna be okay man I
promise you and if you're not feeling
good take a nap or something and take
some positive action but don't sit
around just thinking and for just feel
and move your feet move your feet man
and your brain will follow take action
and you can remedy these you can remedy
these things millions of people have
been through the same type of time
you're having right now and they are
okay and they are living lives right now
that are comfortable and loving and and
there's nothing wrong with you as a
person you know there really isn't man
person you there you were involved some
things right now where you haven't made
some of the best choices that's okay you
know what that is as human and the
beautiful thing is it sounds like
there's a lot of people around you that
also really can see the good parts of
you people are willing to help you out
and recommend you for things and you
know so sometimes if we can't even see
our own beauty we can't even see the
beautiful things that are in us man
because the way that we've
see the world is a little off it's not
the right way or are we in a
kaleidoscope and really it's just some
it's just a pipe or you could just see
through it but we out here kaleidoscope
him and we got to be tuned a little but
keep your help keep your head up man and
be good to yourself dude and just
realize that we're all just people and
that uh that we're trying our best and
it's okay man if you if some things
happen it's okay you know you're not a
bad person okay you just have done a
couple things that aren't working out
for you at this moment but take be easy
on yourself you know it's the same thing
you guys always tell me so I just learn
this from watching y'all but yeah I'm so
excited for Dustin Poirier this weekend
do you guys know I am I'm always talking
about on Instagram and [ __ ] and uh I
just you know you know um he just has I
don't know man the guy just I feel like
he fights for people that can't fight
for themselves a little bit he's that
underdog you know he's that thing inside
of all of us a little bit that and it's
and to me there's just something
inspirational about it and I think it is
to anybody but I'll tell you this man
and this is one time where it makes more
sense than ever do be good to yourself
brother you know be good to yourself man
I mean [ __ ] dude they I was in a so far
in left-field dude I was even one time I
got a job bagging groceries and I was
still in the game
so I you know sometimes life puts us in
some precarious scenarios but that's
okay that's okay man like this is a this
is a challenge for everyone it's a
challenge for everyone so just don't be
too hard on yourself man be all you can
be all right I promise you I promise you
man I felt so bad about myself and and
right now I feel okay
and you will too it's okay man it's okay
and I'll keep repeating that but I just
want to make sure that you know it you
know and that you are that you are okay
it's gonna be alright you guys be good
to yourselves man check out that uh the
whole conversation with them with Billy
come for toes cousin man you got to make
sure that you check that out man Chucky
or Chuck sorry you check out that hole
oh man he just sent me this picture oh
man he just sent me this picture of
Billy's mom wearing the r.i.p Billie
conforto shirt and one of the dogs is
like kind of getting onto her lap a
little bit yeah god is good bro humanity
as powerful dude I'm Chuck he just said
just gave my mom her shirt tears of joy
man yeah it's okay man if we make
mistakes or we mess up because we just
we can we can we can get things back on
track and we can tighten up and we can
affect people we don't know the actions
that you know the friendships we're
going to make the effect that they're
gonna have on people years later years
later there's a picture of Billy
conforto his mom right here wearing a
shirt tears of joy he said you know
that's the power of people right there
yeah we're gonna be okay man you guys be
good to yourselves you know you know
somebody's hands are cold boy hanging
with the mayor mittens dude life is
short but it is sweet man and we're here
together you know and there's a reason
why we're all here at the same time I
believe that you guys be good to
yourselves and we're gonna go out the
way that we came into the world baby but
but shine
[Music]
r.i.p balls
little time for me to sell that parking
brake
[Music]
tell you a story
just embankment gang baby moving way too
fast on a runaway train with come out
[Applause]
[Music]
make sense um what I really see baby
me house it me tell you my story
[Music]
you name a tougher Italian boxer chef
busboy dope runner gay champion dog
owner friend loyal human then Billy
conforto I don't think you can and you
know what man it just shows we're not
just one thing you make some mistakes we
do this you mess up at work you hit a
car you do we're not just one thing man
that thing doesn't define who you are
there are many many things and more
often than not all the things that you
are when we put them together man that
we're okay you know we are a good person
you know just look at the big picture of
who you are cuz I bet it's a nice image
brother
[Music]
you gotta be good to yourselves man
because you deserve it okay